hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video in today's Thursday that means it
is a dev stream recap and as well it is
December 21st and that is the start of
the new winter fall winter season I
believe it's called the frost win
festival or something like that for for
honor which comes with tons of new
things and we're going to be talking
about those things as well as some
little tidbits of information that I
thought you guys like to know so let
some waste a time let's get right into
it so first up we're gonna be talking
about a little bit of information that
happened before the meat and potatoes of
the whole stream and to start off for
honor 1 the best fighting game award of
the People's Choice Award of 2017 so Ken
huge congrats to the team it was
definitely well deserved for honors
definitely one of the best fighting
games I've ever played as well as the
dedicated servers they said are gone are
doing phenomenally well they were
extremely happy with the overall outcome
of it and everybody seemed to be happy
with the connection quality so they're
definitely gonna work on trying to add
it in and implement it into the actual
game and now that we're done with that
let's get into the meat and potatoes of
this actual thing the frost wind
festival event
so first the start off the frost wind
festival event starts today on the 21st
of December and it ends January 4th the
event is going to be coming with some
limited time freezing loot which has
battle outfits and ornaments and an
avalanche effect as well as a few other
things we'll get to in a second but I
want to show you guys the video of the
battle outfits ornaments and the
Avalanche effect so let's roll that real
quick
[Music]
so that was the battle outfits and some
of the ornaments as well as that effect
I hope you guys did enjoy that I thought
that was I thought the Avalanche effect
is pretty nice looking next up it also
comes with color swatches there's going
to be five different wintery color
whitish themes for each character that
you can get for through the loot of the
game which is by go completing matches
or scavenging and then what they're also
adding which they didn't have in the
last event the Halloween event which
they're adding now is exclusive weapons
before we didn't have the exclusive
weapons and now we are so I'm going to
show a few of these images real quick
and kind of talk over them these are
going to be lootable from scavenger
crates or any other game mode and it
drops from the character you were
playing as now it doesn't matter what
they will add there it's going to be the
same regardless of what tier your
character is so say for example your rep
one law bringer you're gonna be getting
the rep the law bring your weapon and
it's going to be a blue but if you're a
rep 10 or rep 15 you're going to be
getting it in the teal it's just it just
depends on what the stats are the
quality of it and what it looks like is
completely the same they wanted to go
for a more icy in winter feel so their
silver was the main type of material and
the color they wanted is instead of the
normal gold that we normally get with
our weapons and might I say these
weapons look absolutely beautiful I'm
under I remember I snagged a few photos
which you might be seeing of warlords
I had Shinobi's I had a bunch of I have
like Ken's days and our emotions they
look absolutely phenomenal once again
huge shout out to the art team for doing
crazily well with all of these the next
thing being added into this mode is
going to be a new game mode it's gonna
be called ice brawlers it's a 2v2 brawl
on a sinking ice Lake map I've talked
about this in multiple other videos
previous to this but as a quick
refresher it is the one similar to the
LOB ringer mission I believe in the
night campaign where you fight the
Viking Raider on the ice where it starts
to crumble and then it eventually falls
into the ocean and then whatever is
standing on that will fall into the
ocean and die it is similar like that so
not only if you have to watch your
opponent you have to watch the ice and
make sure that you live long enough and
don't get thrown off it adds another
layer of difficulty on top of already
watching your opponent and I do like
this it's a big change it's a big switch
up and I love it next up is the frosty
weekly content if you don't remember
from the last event there was two weekly
content
there was going to be one in the first
week and then one on the second week it
is the exact same thing as this but with
obviously a different type of theme now
the first week is going to be masks
outfits they're going to be 15,000 steel
for the first week and then they're
going to go up and price to 20,000 steel
in the second week so if you do have
your steel you want to grab these
immediately and I will show the video
for these right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so those were the mask outfits if you
didn't catch those the samurai got the
dragon the Knights got a Griffin and the
Vikings got a buffalo I don't really
like the fact that the Vikings got
Buffalo if this should have got like
something more terrifying like maybe a
bear but regardless they still look
great and then for the second weekly
content we're going to get the snowball
emote and I'm not going I'm gonna play
the video in the background I'm not
gonna show it it's too short but
basically it is a combat emotes and when
you lock onto an opponent you can throw
a snowball at them and according to the
developers it actually has a little
icicle or icy effect on their screen for
about a couple frames nothing
game-breaking it's not going to be used
in like some meadow where you throw the
snowball and then go for a hit and then
read and then keep repeating that
nothing like that it just for playful
fun and a nice effect to it they're also
coming up with a all-in-one cosmetic
bundle this was also in the last event
but for a recap it comes with the mask
outfit the battle outfit the ornament
the Avalanche effect the snowball emo
and the color swatches for I believe the
one character that you buy the whole
bundle with I believe it's per character
and not perfection this time now the
bundles price will decrease depending on
if you have those items looted so say
for example I believe the base price for
each bundle is 35,000 let's say you play
warden and you have and you want to get
the bundle it's 35,000 base price let's
say that you buy the outfit the battle
outfit the ornaments and like a couple
other things it'll slowly decrease in
price so instead of being 35,000 you
might pay 25,000 the game is not making
you pay double or pay for it again of
the items you already have so the more
that you play the game in the more loot
that you get the less the bundles are
gonna start costing and I'm gonna be
having a video on that later I'm gonna
get the best loot I did this lat for the
last event and it's going to be the
exact same thing as for this one we
could talk about that later and then
they're also going to be have themed
event orders every single day for the
next 12 days it's going to be the Battle
of the twelve days one thumb attic event
order each day for twelve days and it
tells the story of the Battle of the
twelve days it's going to be a little
bit of a lore thing what they did last
event is they had a few typo errors
where it looked like a few letters were
capitalized when they shouldn't have
been it was actually a leak or a hint
kind of
teas for what the actual event order was
going to be that's called apollyon so I
assume they're gonna be doing the same
thing so definitely keep an eye out if
there's a misspelling or something like
that in a certain word in those event
orders so that we can kind of understand
a story or something like that so just
keep an eye out for that and then lastly
we had a they had a short Q&A to finish
the dev stream and it says that you can
elute the event weapons at any
reputation and any rarity like I did say
previously next up they said that the
event weapons are three specific
separate pieces like normal weapons so
there's going to be a blade a handle or
whatever the whatever it happens to be
for your character like it's from wall
bringer it'll be like the hilt the staff
and the blade stuff like that but it's
going to be three separate pieces you
won't just get the whole thing in one go
and then they're also working on two
separate things they're gonna be working
on expanding our inventory space they're
looking or they're cooking up something
for us on how to spend salvage as well
with these more events we're gonna keep
people are gonna start keeping their
event weapons we're gonna start running
out of space real quick right now
they're also trying to work on this but
you cannot change the appearance of
weapons to the event skin if they are
different rarities but they are working
on a solution so you don't have to scrap
your event items and with that being
said guys that is going to be the end of
the video that is all the news we have
for today and about this whole frost
windfall festival if there's anything
coming up in next week like I said I
will do a video on that and I said a
couple minutes ago I do a video on how
to get the how to get the loot the
fastest I assume it's going to be the
same scenario but I'm going to do some
testing about that and supply some
numbers but basically what I did last
event is I showed how to get though the
loot the fastest the quickest cuz there
was so much loot and now that they have
five different colors for each of the
characters and in the exclusive weapons
there's ton of things you have to weave
through to get all this stuff so I'm
definitely going to be checking up on
that and seeing how we can get the stuff
the fastest but anyway if you did like
the video please try to give it a like
it really does help me out if you're new
to the channel please sure to subscribe
I cover the news the leaks the
discussion the information all of our
for honor just to keep everyone up to
date on what is going on in present time
and while you're at it hit the bell
right next to the TV stay notified in my
community post my upcoming streams I do
weekly and all my other videos so you
could be part of that notification squad
and never miss a video of mine but two
most recent videos of
popping up on screen if you guys didn't
miss those I highly recommend you check
those out and with that guys hope we
have a great rest of your day have fun
in the winter fall event and peace out